hey cousin today I'm making fried fish
reminiscent of the beaches in the
Dominican Republic I'm using Fargo red
snapper in English I Pat the fillets
down with paper towels and it might be
long I add five cloves of garlic salt
oregano black pepper paprika for color
and the juice of a lime I mash until it
looks like this I pour the seasoning
over my fish and I rub onto both thighs
I let this marinade for 20 minutes in
the fridge then in a plate I combine
all-purpose flour and some cornstarch I
realize this plate is too small for the
fish I switch over to a bigger plate and
I coat both sides of the fish in the
flour mix I add the fish to my pan with
about half an inch of hot oil and I fry
on a medium-high flame for 3 minutes
then I flipped and another three minutes
I pair my pescado Frito with tostones
and lime and I'm transported right back
to Dr enjoy cousin